[Music]
now the other story that was at the top
of the headlines while i was journeying
across the third world was that of the
nfl head coach who claims that he's
being oppressed and persecuted by the
league which has made him a millionaire
as you may have heard brian flores the
black man was fired by the miami
dolphins after the team underperformed
and missed the playoffs
now the nfl is notorious for firing head
coaches at the drop of a hat if you have
one bad season you're going to be out on
your butt
he may even be fired after a good season
the most infamous such example is marty
schottenheimer back i think it was 2006
2007 he was fired by the chargers
after a 14-2 season
jim harbaugh was run out of town by the
49ers after winning 44 games in three
seasons and taking his team to super
bowl
and both of those coaches by the way are
white
so this rule applies to white and black
coaches like you have to win you have to
win a lot you have to win now you have
to win playoff games or you get canned
because the only thing that the nfl
cares about is winning that's all that
matters
now not all teams are very good at
achieving that objective but that is the
objective nonetheless
so flores he got fired
like many miami dolphins coaches before
him and he could have taken his lumps
and quickly gotten a new job either as a
head coach or a coordinator with a new
team
instead he chose to file a lawsuit
claiming that he's the victim of racism
he says that systemic racism in the nfl
prevents black men like himself from
becoming coaches even though he is a
coach and has been and has held a
coaching job in the league for years
notably the text of his lawsuit which
reads like a compilation of tweets from
accounts with blm slogans in their
profiles
doesn't offer any evidence of racism
instead it makes a series of
unsubstantiated and sometimes quite wild
allegations allegations which if true
still wouldn't amount to racism
flores also accuses the new york giants
of bringing him
uh of bringing him in for an interview
just because he's a minority even though
they had already determined to hire
somebody else
i don't know if that's true or not
but but it might be
and the reason that it might be is that
is because the giants would have been
following the very affirmative action
policies that were meant to alleviate
the mythical racism against black
coaching candidates that flores is
complaining about
so the league has a policy called the
rooney rule which requires teams to
interview minority candidates
even if they already know they want to
hire somebody else they have to bring in
a minority candidate for an interview
that's the rule
the giants followed that rule and for
their trouble they're now being sued for
bigotry bigotry against black coaches
because of a rule that was put in place
for their sake
the nfl has defended itself meekly
assuring the public that it's not
engaging in any conspiracy to prevent
black people from becoming coaches
and yet while defending itself
commissioner roger goodell
still issued a memo stating quote
we will reevaluate and examine all
policies guidelines and initiatives
relating to diversity equity and
inclusion including as they relate to
gender we are retaining outside experts
to assist in this review and we'll also
solicit input from current and former
players and coaches advocates and other
authorities in this area our goal is
simple
make our efforts and those of the clubs
more effective so that real and tangible
results will be achieved
translation we aren't racist but if you
think we're racist then yes we're
totally racist because it would be
racist to tell you that you're wrong
about us being racist
brian flores meanwhile is uh doing the
media tour trying to make his case here
he is with don lemon i believe that the
the system is broken in the national
football league in regards to
hiring minorities and black coaches uh
head coaches and people in positions of
power uh gm head coach
and i'm doing it um because
i think about my my two boys and my
daughter um
and there's there just simply isn't
enough representation
of people who look like them
in head coaching roles in general
manager roles and executive and
president roles in the national football
league uh and i want them to be able to
uh uh
look at those roles i want them to be
able to to look and and believe that
they can they can get into a role like
that and that's simply not the case
right now
inspiring
inspiring poor guy too i mean
multi-millionaire coach in the nfl
nobody has suffered as much as him
except colin kaepernick and you know
the employees of spotify
those are really the the groups in
america in the world that have suffered
the most well uh one thing i can tell
you as a four-star chef myself um
amateur chef but i consider myself a
four-star chef your kitchen is not
complete without
great kitchen knives and that's why you
need cami kota kamikota taps into more
than 800 years of traditional techniques
from honshu japan kamikota also uses
steel source for mills in japan and each
blade is crafted using techniques that
have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife smiths each knife
comes in a beautiful heavy-duty ash wood
box and makes sure that the knife is
stored safely as well each cama-cota
knife goes through a rigorous 19-step
process that takes several years from
start to finish to complete our expert
blade smith's forged shape raw steel
into hearty blades
polishing and sharpening them to
excruciatingly fine edge each knife is
individually inspected kamikoto is so
confident that their knives will work
for you that each knife comes with a
lifetime guarantee because of their
single bevel edge kamikota knives can
achieve an unbelievably sharp edge you
just can't get with other knives they
can cut through your rib eye like butter
that is guaranteed uh camacoto is
currently having a massive extended new
year sale and on top of that sale you
can get an additional 50 50 off any
purchase you make with discount code
matt walsh so click the link below or go
to camacota.com matt walsh and use promo
code matt walsh to save an extra 50
today now yeah he's rich and prominent
and powerful but he could be even more
rich and prominent powerful if not for
all the racism
you know he so so this is a guy sitting
there saying yeah i've got you know 10
million dollars
but i could have 20 million if not for
all this racism
notice how he says the system is broken
with regards to hiring black coaches but
then quickly qualifies by saying head
coaches
why well because in fact there are tons
of black coaches tons of black
coordinators tons of black players and
staff at all levels
black people are massively over
represented in the nfl in comparison to
population size at almost every position
and every level on every team
black people make up 13 of the
population yet nearly 60 percent of the
athletes in the league
but there are a few areas where that's
not the case
which can only be the product of racism
he says
i wonder though
if the system is broken in regards to
hiring blackhead coaches
what about the system in regards to
hiring white cornerbacks
there are currently zero of those in the
entire league
there are also very few white running
backs very few white wide receivers a
few but not many
very few white safeties white
linebackers
the vast majority of the highest paid
stars in the league at most positions
are not white
is that a sign of anti-white bias well
no of course not
because under-representation of whites
is never racism
while under representation of blacks is
always racism
so you see how that works
there's no evidence or reason to believe
that any black man has ever been turned
down for a coaching job because of his
race the claim is preposterous on its
face
though that might
change thanks to the kaepernick the
kaepernick wing of the nfl here's what i
will say
and media matters i can have a lot of
fun with this
if i were an nfl owner
right now
i might at this point actually hesitate
to hire any coach who is not a straight
white male if i'm running an fl
organization the year 2022
i would prefer to hire a straight white
male
why
because a straight white male is the
only kind of coach i can fire without
being sued
flores and his ilk pretend that they're
helping more black people get hired but
the opposite is the case
whereas before race may not have
factored into the equation now owners
have to think when evaluating a black
candidate they have to think well you
know if this guy leads us to a three and
14 season i probably can't fire him
without al sharpton holding a press
conference outside the stadium
but if i hire the white guy
i can fire him after a 14-3 season and
nobody will
care flores doesn't care about that
though because this is all about him
being an nfl coach was profitable
but being a victim is even more
profitable
it used to be something of a joke to
call somebody a professional victim
now that's a literal occupation
available to certain demographics
they even offer college degrees in the
field
why do something for money when you can
sit around crying and make more money
and earn greater adulation for it
that's the calculation flores has made
you can hardly blame him from a
financial perspective i mean it makes
sense
but from a moral perspective and the
perspective of self-respect and dignity
which flores has chosen to forfeit
we can certainly say to him
you sir are canceled well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content